ja tag 32 dieses blutigen krieges
russlands gegen die ukraine auch heute
wollen wir uns die lage angucken und
möchte uns erstmal in die partie hinein
nehmen um einen überblick zu verschaffen
welche bereiche welche teile des landes
wir uns heute ganz genau ansehen
wir haben hier die ukraine und wir
werden uns jetzt gleich drei hotspots
angucken von dem wir ja schon den ganzen
tag gehört haben zum einen erst mal wenn
wir uns lemberg ansehen dort gab es
gestern ja verschiedene angriffe während
ebenso beiden direkt daneben im
nachbarland polen war zum zweiten werden
wir uns auch mario pohl noch einmal
ansehen mario pohl die stadt die
weiterhin eingekesselt wird geschossen
wird da wollen wir uns noch mal wieder
ansehen welche russischen kemper denn
dort überhaupt aktiv sind um zum schluss
gehen wir in den nordosten des landes
nach sumi wo die ukrainische armee auch
heute wieder große geländegewinne
gewinne gegen die russischen invasoren
erzielt
wir gehen mal los mit lemberg wir haben
es schon gehört lembeck wurde gestern
angegriffen mit marschflugkörpern erneut
mit marschflugkörpern angegriffen und
die wurden diesmal gefilmt man sieht
dass hier nicht machen wie kurz auf play
und stoppt das ist relativ gut zu sehen
was wir sehen ist ein kaliber
marschflugkörper der russischen armee
höchstwahrscheinlich abgeschlossen im
schwarzen meer entweder vor der küste
oder saas oder bei sivasspor auf der
besetzten krim dieser marschflugkörper
wurde also gefilmt wie er
aufgeflogen ist und kurz danach gab es
dann auch die einschläge und die
explosion
interessanterweise gab es diese angriffe
parallel zur rede von joe biden oder vor
und nach der rede von joe biden in der
er gesagt hat ja dieser mann putin der
kann dort nicht bleiben der muss dort
weg insofern gehen einige davon aus dass
das auch eine direkte reaktion ist das
also putin gesagt hat passt auf
wenn du da drüben meinen meine absetzung
forderst oder den sturz von mir indirekt
vor dass dann zeige ich dir so nah ich
nur kann am nato gelände was ich machen
kann wie ich sozusagen hier für
terrorangst sorgen kann und ja das
infrage stellen kann so zu sagen was du
machst insofern lemberg gestern abend
angegriffen einem benzindepot wohl hier
getroffen mehrmals vor und nach
sonnenuntergang
viele glauben das ist ein symbol
als zweites wollen wir uns einmal die
panzer ansehen und zwar hat die ukraine
gestern heute wieder zahlreiche panzer
erbeutet und das ganze führt zu einer
unglaublichen situation eigentlich wir
sehen hier zwei panzer der russischen
invasionsarmee die in der region sumi
erobert wurden
nach berichten die wir haben die von der
denkfabrik oryx abgezählt werden hat die
ukraine bei diesem krieg bislang 79
eigenen panzer verloren an die russen
aber 126 erobert bedeutet wir haben ca
40 panzer die die ukraine mehr hat als
zu kriegsbeginn aufgrund eben der
russischen schlechten taktik der
logistik der steckengebliebenen panzer
usw der verlierenden truppen der russen
die ihre panzer teilweise
funktionstüchtig wir sehen uns hier
zurücklassen und sich dann zurückziehen
also die ukraine hat heute laut doris
der denkfabrik 40 panzer mehr etwa als
zu beginn des krieges und zwar alles
panzer russischer produktion mit dem
wladimir putin ins land gekommen ist und
die er dann verloren hat und am ende
dieses videos ist schon ein paar tage
alt möchte ich noch mal zeigen das ist
ja fast schon lustig in der ukraine wie
diese panzer abtransportiert werden wir
sehen hier ein traktor eines
ukrainischen pharmas und der zieht ein
panzer hinter sich her also wenn die
russen weg sind sozusagen wenn sie
geschlagen wurden oder oder geflüchtet
sind dann kommen die ukrainischen frauen
mit ihren traktoren und ziehen die
russischen panzer einfach weg die werden
dann später wieder der ukrainischen
armee übergeben in einigen fällen haben
wir gehört hat sogar die ukrainische
polizei in den letzten tagen elf panzer
beschlagnahmt die von zivilisten einfach
mitgenommen wurden um die eben an die
streitkräfte zurückzugeben
das vielleicht ein bisschen witzig jetzt
kommen wir leider zum sehr ernsten teil
des krieges zum einen noch mal mario
pohl wir haben schon oft darüber
berichtet dass dort nicht nur ja was
heißt nicht nur normale russische
einheiten kämpfen sondern auch eben die
russischen national gerade aus
tschetschenien
die leute von herrn gross und herr
kadyrow ramzan kadyrov putins
statthalter in tschetschenien postet das
auch immer wieder insofern gibt es da
immer neues material gesehen hier wie
brutal dieser häuserkampf geführt wird
und wir hören und das ist auch
interessant immer wieder dieses allahu
akbar allahu akbar gott ist gross gott
ist groß was von seinen kämpfern hier
sozusagen gebrüllt wird um sich selber
anzuheizen
ja sozusagen sich selbst mut zu machen
sie sind auf den erhobenen finger hier
das sind also die islamistische verbände
islamistische verbände die hier aber
schweren russischen panzern gesehen dass
z auf den panzern vorrücken und dort
sozusagen immer immer weiter vorzurücken
wir haben es gehört die stadt ist kaum
noch bewohnt etwa 100000 einwohner sind
noch da und immer mehr von dieser stadt
folgt unter russischer kontrolle in dem
fall fällt unter kontrolle von
tschetschenischen
national garten truppen hier wie gesagt
diese häuserkampf man sieht da wird
nicht differenziert zwischen zivilisten
und soldaten auf der andern seite oder
werden die häuser direkt beschossen und
wer auch immer dann noch drin ist der
wird eben zurück zum opfer dieser kugeln
am ende müssen wir uns leider ein video
ansehen dass uns heute erreicht hat ein
sehr verstörendes video wir haben es
sehr zusammengeschnitten es geht hier
um
russische soldaten die von ukrainischen
soldaten gefangen genommen wurden nach
einem gefecht diese russischen soldaten
sind bereits gefesselt sind teilweise
auch schon mit augenbinden festgehalten
und sie werden und wir werden gleich
sehen von den ukrainischen soldaten
angeschossen sie werden angeschossen
damit sie nicht weiterlaufen können sie
werden in die beine geschossen man sieht
dass scharfe munition benutzt wird
ich habe das jetzt einfach mal laufen
lassen da war der erste der
angeschlossen wird der zweite und der
dritte kniet sich sogar hin weil er sagt
ihr müsst mich nicht anschließen und er
wird trotzdem ins bein geschossen damit
er nicht weiterlaufen kann wir haben das
ganze gepixelt wir haben auch nur einen
sehr kleinen teil gezeigt hier werden
drei leute gezeigt die angeschlossen
werden in diesem video gibt es insgesamt
zehn russische soldaten die alle mit
gleichen wunden an den beinen blutenden
beiden dort liegen einige mit sehr hohem
blutverlust und können kaum noch
sprechen
das ist man muss es so klar sagen wenn
es sich bestätigt dass das hier echte
aufnahmen sind und viel dafür viel
spricht dafür wir haben sowohl ukraine
als auch russen das angucken lassen und
wir wissen dass viele der leute in
diesem insgesamt dreiminütigen video von
dem wir noch ein paar sekunden zeigen
muss sich mit ukrainischen dialekt
sprechen dh wir müssen es so klar sagen
wenn sich das als wahr herausstellt da
ist das ein kriegsverbrechen was sie
gegangen auch von ukrainischen truppen
ein kriegsverbrechen dem
verteidigungsminister rechnet die kof
und präsident zwanziger natürlich
nachgehen müssen das aufklären müssen
und diese truppen dann auch zur
verantwortung ziehen müssen die
natürlich unterhalten umständen kämpfen
ihre familien verteidigen aber das ist
natürlich durch nichts zu rechtfertigen
insofern ein grausiger krieg putins
blutiger krieg der ja immer schlimmer
wird auf und auf verschiedenen seiten
hier zu zu dingen führt zur aktion führt
die natürlich durch nichts zu
rechtfertigen sind dass die situation
heute und damit zurück